mon chéri on est parti à manchester
ensemble on est allé voir un match
ensemble et regardez bien ce qui va
suivre
mehdi est ce que ça a été un des plus
beaux jours de ta vie oui c'est vrai
pourquoi parce que je me serais dit pas
ce à quoi il s'attendait pas à ça
regardez pas ce que c'était ouf
manchester avec me dit ça donne ça
cette semaine
moi je vais à manchester
105 110 destinations
oh
j'aurais aimé tenir ta main un peu plus
longtemps
l'attentât david en mairie ce n'est pas
non plus un but assez pour des dons la
rochelle au stade vraiment le maître du
monde 6 t as tu crois qu'on va voir le
match 2 quad et du fc il à faire contrer
tunis bon par contre j'ai une bonne et
une mauvaise nouvelle
pogba et joue pas ce soir je tue sans
quoi il ya de quoi rien mais non mais
non c'est pas rien taf
c'est la bonne nouvelle
tout près de sa loge on à la loge de
croke park avec petits fours se monte à
ramat petit continue t cha battu à
l'école oui oui oui bien ennemis cédé
2,15 et nous il s'appelle philippe hui
plazy savoir voyager par leur fille
c'est toi qui m'as parlé moi s'inquiéter
du mal de moi mais dès que tu rigoles là
le bouffon de te défonce tout bon c'est
toi qui dit du mal de moi je serais posé
la question j'ai été clair
jo
pourquoi
pour le maillot de manchester
non je t'aime dans la boutique on va les
acheter oui je vais t'acheter maillot
auto manchester où nous on va acheter le
maillot de manchester comme nous je vais
te prendre le connu de ouf d'accord 1
c'est quoi ta taille pour vous en pensez
quoi ta taille
barnak bouffon j'ai trouvé au zoo 12 ans
thot bailly les champs mais tu vas le m
tu vas pécho champ mais je peux prendre
un peu de chance je vais des choses êtes
vous déçu et très bien le français mais
voilà on a tous là on a tout terrain
dangereux ou merci pourquoi
ep
mal par le match
oui
alors laissons
attention la sultane petit ami ton
maillot espèce de bouffon pu alors la
suite arrive oui je voudrais dire paul
pogba bien apprêtée sa loge prévue avec
les garçons y avait du pain mon frère
j'ai jamais mangé tout à m'en suis du
coin comme ça déjà fait route nous ont
fait rire y avait dû par mon frère ça
vient on est très copain pour lui il a
mangé de ouf
comment la base des vu mon frère à noter
dans la loge et où ils te demandes où sa
manchette au wat à manger plus que les
autres il est allé voir le match
manchester contre bof moi oui et après
il ya une surprise de ouf qui est arrivé
oui je sais je sais pas où c'était
est-ce que vous pouvez voir la suite oui
c'est la folie les chéris la wii vous
dit quand je vous dis que c'est la folie
c'est la folie et toi t'as kiffé de ouf
c'est vrai et on y retourne
calme-toi quand même calme toi quand
même pas d'accord il est où ton mari
d'ailleurs soit il est malade
non c'est benjamin castaldi une petit
papillon vraiment comment il s'appelle
déjà
il s'appelle jamais jamais été malade
mon chéri je t'envoie une chorale aucune
allée les chercher
regardez la suite et c'est ouf et
joueurs remerciés je vous remercie et
bien sûr paul pogba et qui est
exceptionnel et raffaella voilà qui a
fait un travail fabuleux
regardez c'est parti
c'est la loge de voir pompey
merci c'est paul midy pour
à 4,5
alors on a kiffé way ou 1 0 bon tu vas
tu content quoi passer une bonne journée
une tribune g en chutant oui la faim
qu'ils mangent ils ont fait recours à la
fois tu préfères point fort tu vas donc
ce n'est pas la première fois que tu vas
manchester ouais sa première fois que tu
joues un match irait que avec moi tu
style laitier d'envoi
c'est quasiment de tout en fait oui j'ai
réussi
juba philippe
déposa
je peux juste d'être une caisse noire
issue
ld com a fait état d' amour merci mais
sous ton côté
c est comment bonjour la santé oms meddy
gerville ou comment vas tu vas bien moi
est content ou est-ce qu'on peut que
laisser pendant trois quatre jours
puisqu'il a fait pour toi tu as lu dans
la loge et ou moins tu vas dans
n'importe quel pays tu feras ce club
merci à sa réflexion au pot de pied
arrêtés
chn
la gagner
la surdité la suite à nos jeunes
entendent parler
merci merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
franchement tu es tu là nous venons
vérité ça marque vraiment vraiment
vraiment plaisir il ya dix parle plus à
tes deux heures je l'entends plume 1 et
largué par les gens même attention à lui
et non pas par des bisous madoff n'a pas
de besoin on joue on n'a pas qui fait
quoi mais aussi des camps les jours
remercier cyril d'avoir organisé cette
journée de haut mais aussi paul pogba
lorsque nous avons reçu chez lui
que tu as fait pour lui la journée qu'on
a passé à sa merci infiniment
et aquitaine